what what is he to you oh he's like he's  a man no ethnicity what's my ethnicity  what's your ethnicity like what would  you call people that look like  you know  in the asian market  hold on i i just need to understand the  things so you're ordering a hooker right  and your description is i want an asian  girl  and then something that looks like him  shows up with a beard and and  at no point are you like what the [ __ ]  are you doing here like how do you say  the asian that we're all thinking about  um  i'll just say asian and just roll the  dice bro  do you guys identify as asian no that's  why they called you in texas  no they call me different things  they just became indian  what did you start as before  what did they call me in texas they  called ice on me in texas  [Music]